Hi, I'm Erik Voss, and my favorite comedy
show is Rick and Morty on Adult Swim. And
ever since I broke down the first
episode of season 3 that was released
early, I've gone back to re-watch the
series again and I've caught so many subtle
jokes that I wanted to point out for you
guys. Now yes, the show Rick and Morty is
packed with references, so I'm going to
skip over the more obvious stuff and point
out the little things that I missed the
first time that made me laugh when I caught
them this time. And you may have already
noticed some of these but '...just just
going go with it you know you know just
go with it and don't stop judging.' And
before I get into these, this video was
brought to you by Quidd. Now you know that
thing where you like toss a sticker
onto a text message? Well, Quidd is an app
that will put on your phone exclusive
stickers like Rick and Morty, and Breaking
Bad stuff, they also have cards and 3d
figures, and it's all free. And we're
going to do a giveaway of a cool-ass
Rick and Morty funko pop vinyl figure,
and I'll get to more details on that
later in the video. Ok, so to get started
the first thing I want to point out is
Rick's burping. Now, this isn't really a
joke, but this specific style of belching
through words is actually a reference to
the old-school comedian Foster Brooks. He
was known from the old Friar's Club roasts.
"Thank you... very much, thank you very much.
As they put... Frederick and gentlemen just
(burp) told you--" Okay, so with that out of the
way, let's look at the first episode, the
pilot. One of the craziest things that
happens this episode is that a kid
freaking dies. Morty's bully and Summer's
crush, Frank. Now, Rick freezes Frank and
he tips over and shatters. And the missable
joke here is that later in the episode,
to honor Frank, the school flies its
flag at half-mast. Also in this episode,
outside Beth's horse hospital, there's an
early establishing shot of doctors
trying to wrangle a fussy horse, but then
later in the episode, they're hosing
down blood stains in the same spot,
implying that this horse didn't make it.
now the second episode is called The
Lawnmower Dog, and that title is a
reference to the 1992 movie, The
Lawnmower Man, where a scientist gives a
mentally handicapped gardener super
intelligence, which is more or less the
premise of the plot in this episode, with
Snuffles the dog.  Now you may notice that Rick
mistakenly refers to the dog as Ruffles,
and Ruffles is the name of the dog in
Justin Roiland's
animated project they never completed
called Dog World about a society of
smart dogs. And one of my favorite jokes
this episode is Snuffles changing his
name to Snowball. "Snuffles was my slave
name. You shall now call me Snowball,
because my fur is pretty and white." And
actually, Snowball was the name of the
evil black pig in George Orwell's Animal
Farm. Now, another inside joke that showed up
in this episode is this guy with the
rainbow suspenders and a football shirt.
According to Justin Roiland, this
character was originally intended to be
the in-universe link among Rick and
Morty and two other shows animated by
his friend, Alex Hirsch, who does Gravity
Falls, and Jason Ruiz who made a show
called Murder Police on Fox that never
aired.
Notice how the football on a shirt has
three Roman numerals on it 18, 3 & 5. Now,
Roiland said that the character would
have had different numbers on his shirt
in the other two shows, and that together
that they would all form a code with
corresponding letters. These numbers
correspond to R, C and E, but of course
we'll never know what that word was
going to be because the other two
animators couldn't fit him into their
shows. So unfortunately, this guy is some
rando who shows up throughout season 1,
in this episode, but also in the
background of Close Encounters of the
Rick Kind, then ranting against
trunkpeople marriage rights in Rixty
Minutes, and then leaving the party
early in the season finale. And then
lastly, in this episode, I love this
little moment when Morty returns to his
family and Summer runs up to hug him,
kind of motorboating him, and Morty
pushes her away. This is because he's
still traumatized from the dream earlier
where his sister was too sexy. Okay, moving
on. I loved all the references in Anatomy
Park to things like Jurassic Park and
Disney World, but one super dark and
really subtle joke that not everyone
caught, but you're honestly pretty lucky
if you did miss it, came from Ethan.
This is Summer's clingy boyfriend.
Remember the character Jacob counseled
Ethan to help him make a breakthrough,
but when you listen to what he says
closely, it's pretty messed up. "My brother...
took me fishing once... in the bushes. I
can't! I can't! He made me feel like a
girl! I may be a girl!" Yeah, I'm not going
to spell out what exactly he means by
that, but I'll let you be the judge.
So episode 4, that was M. Knight Sham-Aliens!,
was also great but I want to skip past it
to my favorite episode of the series,
episode 5 - Meseeks
and Destroy. This of course is the famous
Mr. Meeseeks episode also the episode of
the awful Mr. Jellybean scene. And I
love this little animation detail of
Rick's eyes following Mr. Jellybean as
he leaves the bathroom, then back to Morty
as he puts together what might have went
down. And then later, in that post-credit
scene, when Jellybean's people learn
the horrible truth and decided to hide
it from the world, notice the statue. The
little boy is wearing tighty-whities and
King Jellybean is doing this really
disgusting, subtle lip bite. I also feel
like this whole idea of letting King
Jellybean die a hero is a subtle homage
to the end of The Dark Knight when
Commissioner Gordon decides to cover up
Harvey Dent's dark side so that he can die
a martyr and inspire the people of
Gotham. Even the music here sounds like
it could have been composed by Hans
Zimmer. "Wait. Destroy it."
Okay, moving on to the next episode,
episode 6 Rick Potion Number 9. It has a
few fun missable jokes. First there's
this intercom announcement from
Principal Vagina, warning kids with the
flu not to come to the flu season dance.
"I don't know how many times I have to
say this, but if you have the flu stay
home. The flu season dance is about
awareness, not celebration.
You don't bring dead babies to passo--" Now
this, of course, is a pretty dark
reference of the history of Passover,
where God smited? Smut? Smooted? Smited
the firstborn children of the families
of Egypt. And speaking of dark, at the end
of this episode is one of my favorite
jokes ever from Beth.
"I wish that shotgun was my penis. If it
were, you could call me Ernest Hemingway.
I don't get it and I don't need to." Now,
considering the writer Hemingway killed
himself by putting a shotgun in his
mouth, you can probably guess what she
was going for... The next episode is
Raising Gazorpazorp, which opens with a
pretty great missable joke, the family
debates over whether to intervene with
Morty humping his sex robot upstairs, but
then something goes wrong. "Um Rick ,could
you come with me please? Quickly? Okay, now
if we hear squeaking we intervene." And I
love to call back in the next scene.
"Unacceptable! Oh." Also in this episode, the steps
on the female gazorpazorp court say
Sis Semper Calumniam, which is Latin
for you're always wrong. And Summer says
this to defend herself - "And if you think
my top is cute, you cannot execute." This
is a reference to Johnnie Cochran's famous
defense in the OJ Simpson trial "If it
doesn't fit, you must acquit." Then at the
end of this episode, Morty Junior's angry
dance is a reference to Kevin Bacon's
angry dance in Footloose. Now the next
episode is Rixty Minutes, aka the
first interdimensional cable episode, and
for this episode, many of the shows that
they watched were improvised by Justin
Roiland in the audio booth - that's why
you can hear him breaking character a
few times.
"I'm Gazorpazorp (bleep)field, bitch now give
me my (bleep) enchilada. Called two brothers. Two
brothers.
It's just called two broth--" I also love where the
camera flashes past a channel with a
music video of Michael Jackson's Thriller
with phone people. So this is the phone
universe from
Close Rick-counters of the Rick Kind.
Now the next episode, Something Ricked
This Way Comes, has a bunch of little
Easter eggs that you probably already
spotted, to things like Adventure Time,
and Stephen King, and Steven Jobs, but the
one that I only now just caught was in
the closing X gonna to give it to ya
montage. The bully that they beat up in the
schoolyard is a grown-up version of the
character Randall from the show, Recess.
Okay, moving on to Close Rick-Counters of
the Rick Kind, which introduces us to all
the other Rick's and Morty's from
different universes. So for example, in
the background of the Citadel, there's a
Cronenberg Rick and Cronenberg Morty,
presumably from their c-137 universe
that got Cronenberged. I also like the joke here
when the Ricks examine Rick's portal gun.
"Oh come on, don't look at another man's
portal gun history. We all go to weird
places!" Now of course, this is a reference
to the universal anxiety of someone
looking at all the porn in your internet
search history. But if you think about
this, this is hilarious, because this is how Rick
looks at the universe. Just surfing
through different porn web sites and
getting off. Okay now up next are two of
the craziest visual gags in this
entire series. So first up, I mentioned
Gravity Falls earlier, and a big
reference comes in this episode. So when
the Rick's are chasing our Rick and
Morty through the portals, if you look
closely a few random objects fly out of
this one. It turns out that is the same
mug and other belongings of Gruncle
Stan from an episode of Gravity Falls
when he loses them in a portal. And I'll
get to that second crazy, visual gag in a
second, but first I want to thank Quidd
for sponsoring this video. Quidd is an
awesome new app where you can collect
great stickers, and cards, and 3d figures
for free all on your phone. So if you use
emojis and stickers when you text your
friends like I do, Quidd has thousands of
free stickers that you can't find
anywhere else from great shows like Rick
and Morty, and Adventure Time, and Bob's
Burgers, Steven universe, Power Puff Girls
and Family Guy, and cult hits like
Breaking Bad and Star Trek, and games
like Five Nights at Freddy's. And hey,
look at me! You can drag and drop these
stickers on iMessage. Like when you're
chatting with your buddy, and he's
pressuring you to 'Ah geez! go on an
adventure that you're just not ready for!'
And if you collect Funko pop figures,
Quidd has those, too.
Actually, we're going to do a giveaway
where if you share this video on Twitter
with
the hashtag #newrickstars will pip you
adorable poopy buttholes, and send you a
funko pop vinyl Rick and Morty figure.
Yeah get on this, these things are awesome. Now
some of these stickers, cards, and toys on
Quidd are super rare and hard to get, so
good luck! But the good news is that you
can meet cool people on Quidd, look at
their collections and trade with them
just as easily and as quick as chatting
with each other. And as a new feature you
can showcase your collection by adding
stickers to images you already have on
your camera roll, including a new pack of
new rockstars themed stickers, like our
lightning bolt and then red arrows, and
circles, so you know when something's
really important. Just, please don't put
any of those circles or arrows around my
nipples. You're already doing it. I know
you're doing it. Why did I say it? What was I
thinking? Just check out the profile tab
on iOS. New stickers, cards and figures
that again, you can collect for free, are
released every day, and I hear that
they're going to drop a new collection
for a property that, just saying, if you
like this channel, you're gonna want to
get it on. Just click on the link in the
description and follow us on Quidd. Our
username is new rockstars. Add us as a
friend! You can trade with us. Come on,
let's get closer and be more than
friends. I think we're ready. Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so back to this episode. The other
crazy visual gag comes in this awesome
montage with Rick and Morty running
through various alternate dimensions of
chairs and pizzas and phones. And if you
look closely at the background, you can see
the framed portraits are changing as well.
But the one that blew my mind is that
later in this chair universe, Rick and
Morty pass a homeless chair who drinks
out of a bottle that shaped like a tiny
bus, and then immediately after the bus
that passes Rick and Morty is in the
shape of a bottle. This attention to
detail is insane. Also later in this
episode, doofus Rick tells Jerry about
Eric Stoltz mask Morty. And this
reference to Eric Stoltz
is a subtle nod to Rick and Morty's
origin as Justin Roiland's animated Back
to the Future parody short called Doc
and Marty, which he had to change for
legal reasons to Rick and Morty. And a
little history on Back to the Future
here, the part of Marty McFly was
originally played by actor Eric Stoltz
before he got replaced by Michael J Fox
because they wanted the characters be a
bit more comedic. So the season 1 finale
is Ricksy Business with the house party.
So Rick tells Summer that her improvised
nonsense word of glip glop is a hate
word.
"Are some glip glops from the third dimension
going to come over and play cards or
something?
Glip glop? You're lucky a trapthalorkian doesn't hear you say that. It's like
the n-word and the c-word had a baby and
it was raised by all the bad words for
Jew. Then later, Rick totally
appropriates this hate word "Yeah, what up
my glip glop?" And one of the guests at
this house party is a staircase person
from the tavern in the Meeseeks and
Destroy episode. Now I love the
character of Abradolf Lincler. All
of his lines stem from the fact that
he's half Lincoln half Hitler, and this
one's my favorite. "Prepare to be emancipated
from your own inferior genes!" And
later, in this episode, Rick grinds up the
crystal kalaxian and snorts it, leading
them to this choreographed dance. And
then when Morty angrily throws a crystal
outside, the interdimensional monster
snatches it and eats it, and then shortly
after that you can see the creature also
happily doing the Rick dance in the
background. There's also this really
dirty joke from Tammy. "I love watching bukkake.
I mean, I don't know would I personally would ever do it?"
Okay, so kids, cover your ears, but bukkake
is a Japanese term for a sexual act that
involves lots of men doing something to
one woman, or man. And then later in this
episode, Tammy
flirts with birdperson "I'm not looking to get into a soul bond, I'm just looking for... I
believe birdperson can arrange that." Sh
it sounds like bird person is planning
a bukkake. I don't even know how you
would begin doing that. Okay, moving on to
season 2. The season 2 premiere is A Rickle in Time, which opens with this
great meta joke "Phew. Man that guy is a
red grin grumble - pretending he knows
what's going on. You agree, huh? You like  that red grin grumble reference? Well guess what?
I made them up. You really are your
father's children. Think for yourselves,
don't be sheep." So Rick is basically
making fun of all the young fans of this
show who laugh along to references that
they don't understand, like bukkake. I
hope you don't understand what that is. And
the next episode of season 2 is Mortynight Run, with the character of Fart,
voiced by Jemaine Clement. And I really
appreciated this subtle joke: "I
communicate through what you call
Jessica's feet, no telepathy." Just to be
clear, Fart is reading Morty's mind here,
which is, yeah, currently thinking about
his crush, Jessica's feet. So the song
that Fart sings is Goodbye Moon Man,
and Jemaine Clement is invoking David
Bowie. He actually did a Bowie parody on
his show Flight of the Concords. Also in this
episode, in the arcade Blitz and chips,
there's a cameo by Mr. Meeseeks in the
background.
He's helping another alien win a pinball
game, and then when he's successful, Mr.
Meeseeks vanishes. We also see the Jerry
day care center, where the music that's
being played is human music, which is the
same song from Jerry's simulation back in
season one, in M. Night Sham-aliens. "And now,
here's human music. Boop-boop-boop. Boop-boop-boop. Hm. Human music. I like it. Well look at this fella. Aren't you handsome? Thank you."
The next episode is Auto-erotic
Assimilation and the title itself is an
amazing pun. It's also a reference to
another sex act which is a callback to
what Morty and Jessica walked in on squanch
doing in the previous season finale.
Now this is the episode with Unity.
That's Rick's ex-lover who's
consciousness took over an entire planet.
My favorite joke here is a reference to
Dan Harmon's previous TV series, Community.
So notice how Rick's watching TV. He's
playing God, forcing the characters to
have sex on the table, and then canceling
and uncanceling the show "Okay now put it back on!
Alright I'm bored." which are both things
that happened on Community. Okay, the next episode,
Total Rickall" is another favorite of
mine from the series. The concept of a
parasite that creates false positive
memories? It's just so ingenious. And one
mystery here at how this parasite made
it into the house in the first place.
Remember, Rick accuses Summer. "Somebody
probably tracked it in last week on the
bottom of their shoe, or on a piece of
alien fruit. Someone? Get off the high
road, Summer! We all got pinkeye because
you won't stop texting on the toilet." But if
you look closely at this, there's
actually a little visual callback that
answers this mystery. Early in the
episode, Rick throws out these green
rocks. And he got those rocks back in
Mortynight Run, and notice how they have
these little pink warts on them. These
are the same pink warts that are on the
parasite corpses, so really it was Rick
that tracked in the parasite from the
beginning. And one thing that you might
have caught is that Mr. poopy butthole
was edited into the opening credits,
partly to tease this idea of false
memories changing our view of the past,
but also this makes sense because these
clips in the opening sequence are
horrifying, negative memories, proving
that mr. poopy butthole is actually real.
Now in this episode, Rick talks about how
he hoards a supply of limited edition
Nintendo 3ds's, which Justin Roiland
actually said is something he did in
real life, hoping that he'd be able to
cash in on them some day. But one little
clever joke that I liked in this episode
came from Frankenstein admitting he was
wrong to gang up on Summer. "I was on the
wrong side of the pitchfork on this one.'
I'm not even gonna explain that one, that's just great. So after this episode, is Get
Schwifty, which includes an animated
cameo by Justin Roiland. He's the guy
being sacrificed to the head god with a
sign saying thief. And in this episode's
amazing post credits scene, ice T
transformed back into water T and he
attacks the numericons, shooting the
numbers 6 & 7, which is a reference to
Tech 9 album, sixes and sevens. The next
episode is The Ricks Must Be Crazy,
where Rick and Morty go into the
different layers of the microverses.
Zeep, who's voiced by Steven Colbert,
says this: "I dropped out of school. It's
not a place for smart people."
Now this detail is meant to parallel the
character to Rick, who said pretty much
the same thing back in the first pilot
episode. "But I'll tell you how I feel
about school, Jerry - it's a waste of time."
There's also a little little joke when
Rick remembers that he screwed around
with a society in the Microverse "(bleep) You!
What did you say to me? (Bleep) you. You told me it
means much obliged. And then this gets
called back later this episode. "Much
obliged."
I also appreciated in this episode how
Rick uses the same hidden snake trick
that he used in Get Schwifty to make
the president think you can turn people
into snakes. Okay skipping past Big Trouble
in Little Sanchez, to the second
Interdimensional Cable episode, the little
bits commercial in this episode? When the
guy swears in front of children, one of
the kids looks up at him and shoots
them a dirty look. Now, the next episode
is the purge episode Look Who's Purging
Now, where Summer blows a hole in the
garage roof, which gets called back in
the following episode, when the hole
appears freshly patched in the opening
establishing shot. Now that brings us to
an even 50, but I'm having fun. Let's keep
going into season 3. Now I already did a
breakdown of the first episode of season 3,
so definitely go check that out. I
already pointed out a few great
missable jokes. First there was the
memory of Rick in the background as he
reacts to 9/11 footage.
"Fine, but I'm driving." Morty
also alludes to finding Jerry's
mannequin leg, which is a reference to a
video that Dan Harmon made that showed
him humping a mannequin leg in his bed.
There's also a few Easter Eggs for
Gravity Falls, like there's a mabel morty
and a dipper morty, there's also a quick
frame that shows the outline of Rick's penis. But there were three other things
that I didn't point out in this episode.
First, in the garage there's a framed
picture of Doofus Rick in the cabinet.
That presumably belongs to Jerry, who
remember got along with him so well in
that season one episode. Clearly he
misses him so much. And then also in the
false memory that Rick created of his
origin story, his 1998 house is a
recreation of Walter White's house in
the show Breaking Bad. Notice how the
house layout, and architecture and even
the bushes in the front yard are exactly
the same. This makes sense, because like
Heisenberg, this version of Rick is the
kind-hearted family man who ends up
using his scientific brilliance for evil
purposes.
Then finally, season three showed us a
new end card to the episode that usually
shows Dan Harmon's production company
logo. Before, it was claymation that
showed Harmon and his wife, happily
watching TV. But now, this one shows
Harmon after his divorce, alone on the
couch, probably drunk. Depressing
and hilarious. Now again, there are lots
of things I didn't cover on this list,
and a lot of it are just references and
jokes that I found a little obvious, but
I'm curious - what do you think I missed?
If there ends up being a lot, I kind of want to
make a second follow-up video to this
with even more jokes and references. But
come on, hit me up in the comments; let's
give each other even more reasons to
laugh at the show. Show me what you got!
And subscribe to new rockstars so you can
watch any other Rick and Morty videos we
make, and you can help make Rick and Morty a
bigger priority for us by liking this
video and sharing it and tweet about it
and keep a link to the video in your
tweet. You can also be a bigger part of
new rockstars by contributing to us on
patreon. Big thanks to all of our current
donors, especially BM Havoc. You can
tweet me your favorite Rick and Morty
jokes (@eavoss) or follow new rockstars on Twitter (@newrockstars) for
updates on our videos. Bye.